all right justin justin uh where'd you
grow up where you from originally uh i'm
from
uh upstate new york small town called
amsterdam which is just
outside of albany which is the state
capitol of course um
yeah i grew up in uh i grew up in a farm
basically
or a farm area what was your childhood
life you had both your parents yeah both
my parents um
i had a great childhood really um
i mean you'd see it as great but there
was you know there's always stuff right
um the underlying stuff
which kind of defines you as a person i
feel like as you grow older
um because you know like if i had
you know i raced motorcycles that was
going to be my job originally
in high school like i didn't really i
had a lot of friends in high school but
i
was always on the road traveling or i
was
um racing um so i didn't really
um hang out as much as a lot of kids did
in you know like seven through
you know grade six through probably six
six through ten i was not not around
that much as i was racing motorcycles
and um
so my childhood was pretty cool um you
think so it was
it was cool but then again once you get
through high school
and you start becoming who you are which
i think kind of happens in the high
school area
um you know things got weird because i
was
um different you know than the other
kids
and um some kids thought it was great
you know and then
of course there's others that didn't and
different in what way well
you know like i you know i
raced motorcycles and i and i rode
skateboards
and i didn't do the things that the kids
in the schools and my classes did then
you know
football basketball that's everything
that sounds kind of lame right now but
then
at that point in time it was a deal in
high school it just was
different and that was awkward because i
didn't um
spend a lot of time with other kids i
was you know always
doing something else so i didn't have
like you know the social skills that
other people did
i had the social needs you know like i
desired you know girlfriends and all
that sort of thing but
i didn't you know have that connection
that other kids did so
um it made a little awkward and
a lot of kids thought it was like the
coolest dude but those kids didn't
really matter
per se to the other shooting it's very
in high school can be brutal
um if you're not prepared for it you
know
um emotionally and sometimes i just
wasn't so
um but all in all i mean that's probably
looking at some of the other um people i
have in my life today the way they
probably grew up
in their childhoods mine compared to
theirs it's
probably [ __ ] amazing um so
you can't really complain you know good
relationship with your parents
yeah i agree with my parents my parents
are really good people um
still married they've been married
forever um
they actually got divorced when i was
like
just before i started the motorcycle
thing they were divorced for a couple
years
and i cried for two whole years i think
as a child
until they got remarried together and um
which is pretty cool
everything was okay after they got back
together yeah yeah it was rare to see
something like that i was actually my
dad's best man
at his wedding but the two years where
they were separated
yeah my father my father builds um
as a fabricator and he designs and
builds chassis for a stock car
so he builds race cars and of course
custom cars and motorcycles and that
sort of thing so
i believe i don't know exactly what
happened with my parents but i think my
father was
was spending a lot of time with that and
i think that and i know that he was i
mean they had
not a drug problem but he was doing
drugs that my mother really wasn't
uh okay with at that time
so i think that he had um
you know made the right the proper
changes
so to speak and i think that my father
and i know that the family is probably
more important to him than yeah
anything else so after school your your
life went where
so yeah my my parents are great my legs
back to my parents my parents are really
good people and my father was
a real big presence in my life which i i
think is a
huge thing asset or just
for life in itself like because i have a
lot of friends of mine
a lot of close friends and i know a lot
of the ones that don't have fathers and
father figures in their life and they
gender they tend
and i hate to say this but they tend to
have a hard time dealing with other men
in life you know um because they don't
know how to do it they were never taught
how to deal with another man
as a child so but i did and i'm really
grateful for that
so um after high school i
my father was like you you know my
father has a
shop i could have easily done what he
does
but in my heat and my father wasn't no
part of that and um after my motorcycle
career
what ended because i just didn't want to
do it anymore i was i was tired of
breaking bones
um i just uh my father was like you
gotta go to school
or you can't do it here basically
and i was a little child the thought of
like
not being at that time there was there
was not even a thought of
any other idea than besides you know
doing what my parents said
so i did what they said and i went to
school i went to the school of visual
arts in new york city
um which was
awesome but my education really didn't i
i was always a
you know fairly i was gifted i guess or
good
natural um because i grew up in a shop
with my father
i always understood you know structure
and you know the general dynamics of
construction or building it just that
came to me actually and then
i had a natural sense for art and form
and color
so it was pretty school was pretty easy
for me
but my education in school i didn't
really get from school
i got from from the people around me
really because i learned
what i learned in in college is it's you
know and then they say
and people say you know who you what you
know who you know
and and uh and the the
the pat the pack that you run with you
know that sort of thing
so when i went to when i went to college
i was fortunate enough to you know i
lived in the dorms i was i was like
because i
my at this point in my life like i had
it with my small town
um i was super uncomfortable there and
um
i wanted i wanted out you know i want to
get [ __ ] out of there and
when i had gotten my uh was able to get
accepted to school of visual arts
i literally made my father drive me to
school like a month early
because i think our the dorms were
available early august
and um school started in september
so as soon as the dorms were available i
made my i asked my father to
drive me to school and he said your
school's not for another three weeks i
was like i just went out of here
so he dropped me off and he gave me a
hundred dollars and he said good luck
figure it out and i did
and um i always worked so
working for me was just natural it's
like because i had a good father you
know like
he taught me what to do you know you
work
so as soon as i got there you know i i
tried living off
of my mom mother father's money that
they gave me 100 a week
in new york city and literally like my
father gave me a hundred bucks the next
four hours that money was gone and i was
[ __ ]
penniless with you know um you know i
had a meal card and stuff so i could get
some food
but like my dorm was on uh 77th and
broadway
and school of visual arts is on 23rd so
uh to every 10 miles is a every 10
blocks is a mile so it's you know
seven miles to school every day so i'd
skate and i'd have no money and i'd be
skateboarding skating down
you know broadway every morning to go to
class and that got old real quick
and so i got a job you know and i
i got a job at uh first i got a job at
paragon sports on
18th street and broadway um and then i
wanted to work in the club because i
that was fun you know and but i had no
idea how
difficult how big of a deal it was to
get a job as a bartender in new york
city like i thought
you could just go apply and you know
yeah sure we'll hire you but it's not
like that at all
but i eventually i i had answered an ad
to work um they um
oh god wasn't even it's a really big
club on 11th street and broadway
um not club usa jesus christ you know
come to me but i went out answered an ad
for them
um and webster hall it was a
as a it was an open call for bar backs
bartenders
and servers at webster hall i don't know
if anyone knows anything about clubs
there's still web charts probably one of
the biggest
there is to be got in new york city so i
just went
and i saw this ad in the back of the la
or new york 4-1-1
and i had this idea of just going down
and i wasn't going to go but i decided
to go
and there was literally 800 people in
line to go for these jobs
and the line was like around the [ __ ]
block three blocks and you couldn't even
see the entrance way to the club
so i just waited in line i waited and i
waited
and i started talking to some people and
it was fun and we and i waited and
finally got to the door
and i had no resume i had nothing and
i they had given me their standard you
know fill it out application i filled it
out
and i had no bartender experience at all
to speak of
i just but i did have was a mason i
worked as a mason and
this summer's my father got me a job
working for his friends as a mason
and i put that on there because that's
what i had and when i went downstairs to
see the guy who had a bulletproof vest
on and he was a big italian dude and
there were
other guys with bulletproof vests on
standing around as pretty gangster
um he looked at my resume and he looked
and i backed and i was in pretty good
shape i worked out a lot and
took care of myself and um
he looked at me and he looked at my
resume and he said oh you're a mason huh
i was like yeah you because you're
italian i was like yeah i'm half cuz
what's the other half i go irish he goes
all right all right
he goes well my families are masons for
seven seventh generation masons from
italy
and i was like cool man and he's like
he's like he looked at me and he goes
all right how many
cases of beer do you think you can carry
do you think he carried two on his
shoulder
i said yeah all right and he looked up
and down a little bit and he says
oh you're in he goes i like you're mason
i know you can work
you know then that then it was in there
sitting there and it goes if i got to
say it again
you're out so get back into the room and
i walked back in this other this little
room in the back and there was like
you know six or seven other people who
would look like they just won the lotto
and they were like oh you got into i was
like yeah i was like you don't know how
lucky you are i was like lucky why he's
like
well this is a this is a big deal like
kind of a big deal for
this you know the thing you know they
had to get this job and
and that was it and i was working at
webster as a bar back and which is
you know where i started learning a lot
of stuff about like um
you know navigating through the social
networks of near you know new york and
you know it was the beginning because i
knew nothing about any of it i was just
some kid from upstate new york that
didn't know [ __ ] all
and um i went quickly you know and then
i met a couple i met this woman who was
pr person and she met saw me in the club
and i was a good attractive
kid back then and she picked and become
like dating her
and i went sydney and sydney would make
one phone call and got me a job as a
bartender at another club called
called la barbat on 57th to 8th to 9th
which
i was there for a while and dated the
staff
and it was um so i you know you make
this a point
like when i met and i saw the what
how i know the word power was but the
ability that she had to open doors
for me um like you know because i could
have still
easily just been sitting in my [ __ ]
dorm room
broke trying to figure things out but
you know get getting out and
you know being fortunate enough to get
that job at
at webster hall and then when i after
that you know because
the and a lot of it because i was
attractive
and that helps you know so you know a
lot of girls you gravitate towards you
know what they do
because it's it's just what you have
available to you and you use what you
have available to you to
get by or get ahead but you know and
it's
it's up to you and and um especially in
the arts you know like the arts is
a gnarly game because you know even
after i graduated school like when you
graduate school
you know you spend all this money on art
school there's like no job placement
[ __ ] good luck slap your ass go make
smart you know but pay your dues you
know pay around you know pay your bills
so you know you have all this money you
got to pay back for loans
then you got to you know you don't know
what to do you know and
you know very few people come out of art
school and do it actually do anything
as i'm still on facebook and instagram
with all the care guys i went to school
with
you know and like maybe ten percent of
them are actually doing it
the other are doing something else
whatever it may be you know
um so i you know it makes my point
like all right my learn my lesson my
what i learned in college i i learned
from i don't want to say the streets but
but
from navigating socially like i just
learned that's really who you
are around who are you with and
you know like i think the guy's name
from now or from
sex pistols like malcolm mclaren was the
guy who was their promoter i think
he like says sex pistols suck dude as a
as a band they like they're really that
good
i thought they were great i know but you
know like
back then when punk first started like i
don't know man
not technically maybe but but the energy
was the energy was but
that a lot of that was because malcolm
mclaren sold them as these
as this thing and they became like this
super star
yeah you know what i'm saying like
without malcolm mclaren they were white
hot for about a year
all right for the at the hell until they
self-destructed right as their helmet i
don't
know
i don't know that they would have been
the sex pistols as we know them you know
what i'm saying it's like
how you promote yourself it's and you
know or
um you know there's lots of other
examples but
my point is it's like being as an artist
um
and being in the arts it's like i know
lots of dudes that are so [ __ ]
talented man they're
so [ __ ] talented but like they're
just boring dudes
and they don't and i hate to say it
you know who am i to judge anybody but
like they're just
they're not out there and they're not
promoting themselves and like especially
today you look at people like on
instagram or and like [ __ ] it's like
some people don't do anything at all and
they're they don't do anything
they don't do anything like i'm still
i'm still trying to figure out there is
the kardashians do i know i'm not sure
what the [ __ ] it is
they do but they are you know everyone
knows who they are
and that's just their ability to promote
themselves which as far as i know comes
from their mother
um she's probably brilliant woman but um
so so drugs came into your life yeah so
yeah well they always did
and you know i even back then like i
i had dated this you know like it
started in college
it was it i i had one when i was working
in la barbat i had dated this girl who
can't turn out to be a playboy playmate
of the year and
um carrie stevens can i say that yeah
uh anyways and me and carrie dated for a
hot for a while
and she had been married to the
drummer from kiss and he died from his
drug abuse you know
and she was not [ __ ] uh you know she
had
just lost him you know and i still don't
know why the [ __ ] she was working as a
cocktail waitress but i just think that
she was
bored i guess but she was a cocktail
witches there and
um she uh so anyways i i
achieve i i of course at the club
there's tons of drugs so i was doing
tons of
cocaine and i um and she saw me one
night with my
like my nose running and [ __ ] and she
scooped it up and put in her mouth and
she was
she says that's you know and that didn't
last very long
so uh and but back then i i had lots of
options i guess so it didn't bother me
as much because i was
so fresh and so new um i hadn't had my
ass kicked enough yet my life to really
see what was going on right so but you
know shortly after that
you know and i had started doing a
little bit of heroin in in high school
right after high school and then i um
wasn't you know like a junkie and i
didn't really shoot dope
but you know i thought it was a cool
thing to be doing for whatever reason
and i after one of the cl one of the
nights we were going to the club
some other bartenders were for from from
new york from brooklyn these brooklyn
dudes who are
like a different breed altogether um
took me to
like a tattoo party like after hours
with a bunch of bikers
um at some hells angels house in
brooklyn and i
the last thing i remember was was
trading a
bag of heroin for the tattoo i have on
my back
and i slumped over the front of a chair
first so he could do like which isn't
called now a [ __ ] stamp but back then i
don't think there were [ __ ] stamps
strippers hadn't yet ruined it yet so um
i got the tattoo and i and i overdosed
um and died in this guy's bathtub
and i woke up the next morning luckily
uh i came to but i had
die i had died i guess and my body had
gone to like rear mortise
where you and your in your body you know
let's loose all the lactic acid
so like i my body was so stiff
like it took me uh to walk from here to
the psych there to the end of the
seamless
to the beginning of the cove you know an
hour
it was so incredibly painful and the
sound and i
and i remember i they had taken my shirt
off somehow
and then i woke up in the bathtub and
there was a little bit of water left and
i say it thrown on me i guess
or tried to wake me up and keep me a lot
keep me awake and
i just walked down this it was a
railroad apartment in brooklyn
so i walked down this you know this long
hallway
and it took me and i like it was so
painful in my head
and everything and my eyes were so like
that cord
and i walked down this long hallway and
i got today and they were playing i
remember they were playing [ __ ]
mario brothers these two bikers and the
one looked over his shoulder and he was
like oh
man you made it we thought we lost you
there i was like
yeah thanks man he goes yeah well the nr
train's right there in the corner
uh you can probably catch everything
back to manhattan
you know uh you know i have a good one
you know basically and and you know come
to find out
like back at the back of that my buddy
who brought me already said that you
know they
they must have liked you because like my
father was a biker and i said that
because normally they would just throw
you out of the house and let you die in
a [ __ ] street
um seriously they're not big into people
overdosing in their house
so i'm pretty lucky for that um
and i [ __ ] walked back to my [ __ ]
dorm i walked back to the train station
and just the sound of that and that
train clanking
it was [ __ ] awful and um i
after that i had done maybe a couple of
him but i was done with it pretty much
after that that was
but i'm lucky to be alive for sure
um and then you know so but after the
cocaine was
like i always did a lot to blow you know
and
i had another girlfriend after that that
i met at the club that's that same club
this girl raven who we were together
with for many many years and
i met her there and then when i i got
thrown out of them the dorms ended
um and i basically stayed in my dorms
the dorms like school ended and there
was summer
and i i just stayed in my dorm and no
one ever came to check up on me
so i just stayed there and i was working
at the club um
and september came
and because i saw kids started coming in
and i didn't see i just stayed and
finally like one day this woman comes to
my door and asks my daughter and she
goes what are you doing here i was like
i live here she goes you're still here
i'm
what i mean i'm like okay well listen i
don't know what's going on
but all i know is there's something else
coming in this room in the next you know
here tomorrow morning so you're gonna
have to go you can't live here anymore i
was like
really she's like yeah i was like okay
so
you know i was kind of oblivious but i
kind of knew what's going on at the same
time
so i just stayed so i and then so that
ended i ended up moving in with my
girlfriend raven
who i was dating uh at the time there
and we were together for a long time but
um after school ended and that was that
summer
um here's like part of where like the
my school you know like my
lessons in life or what i've learned in
school because i i learned a lot in art
school i did
but again i learned mostly about
everything
that carried me out into my where i am
today from my lessons i learned through
people and situations and
you know like when you're getting out of
a college you don't really
know what you're gonna do and i and um
so i had these experiences uh in new
york
and i um i
was living with my girlfriend raven at
the time and
i my roommate from college whose um
cousin is a big producer in in hollywood
um one of the biggest actually
if you've ever seen top gun you that's
who you know that's who he is
so randall's that's where um that's my
roommate's cousin
and um so he was going out here to
to do his uh to prove you know to pursue
his his career
and i was still kind of like trying to
figure out how to be an artist in new
york
and which is incredibly difficult if you
don't know
um because i'm going around you know
it's just there's no
it's tough you know and you just gotta
paint or you gotta sculpt
and then you just have to do a whole
bunch of it but how do you connect
yourself
to the world that you want to sell it to
there's no real way to
do you have to figure that out on your
own you have to either be savvy or or
not and
back then there's no internet and um
you know i didn't even have a cell phone
yet or a pager so there's none of those
things
i think the pagers have existed the cell
phones are just starting to come out but
um i i just had no idea what i was doing
so
he had called me and flew me out to la
to help him with uh his first film
project here because he was you know
it's easier for him because of course
his cousin is a producer
um so i ended up coming out here based
on that
and um my girlfriend at the time
who i had moved into because i was you
know still living in my dorms and
you know school ended and i i just
stayed in my dorms i just never left
because i
i didn't no way i was going back to my
parents house there's no
way i was going to go back home ever um
and with my tail between my legs
so i just stayed in my dorm because
that's what i do knew and no one had
said anything so i just stayed
and then september came and then uh you
know woman knocks on the door and
she's i open she goes what are you doing
here i was like i live here
you can't live here are you still here
from last season i'm
i'm like i guess she goes well you have
to go
tomorrow morning someone else is coming
in this room and can you clean up a
little bit i won't say anything just
just you know you have to go so i ended
up i called my girlfriend and she
let me move in with her and i lived with
her and
um so then you know uh and then i moved
out to l.a i came up to la for this
to help my buddy with his film you know
and he wanted me to make me as
production designer art director and i
didn't know anything about it and i took
film as a minor
i you know took some film classes really
but i i uh
i was a sculpture major and
but i you know i had an idea what he was
supposed to do
but this is probably the first project
fell through and
then he kind of left me hanging a little
bit but he did get me
what i come to find out weren't two real
incredibly important things in la
uh a is a place to live um and
be a connection to something uh to some
people
um phone numbers to call um we
and there were two people who were
pretty well woven into the fabric of
hollywood and um
i just caught them and and what i do
know about people in la
and people are there's a lot of [ __ ]
talking about people in l.a
but in my experience in la like people
have gone through it themselves where
they've
you know they've struggled and they
needed to get ahead somehow
and they've had someone open the door
for them they had someone help them out
and so they're they're always in my
experience
you know available to help you out and
they will
if you know they feel that you're going
to do it you know
um worthy of it or whatever that is
and so i i call these people and they
you know they made a few phone calls and
and got me going and got me you know got
me a couple jobs as a pa
and other things and um
you know and what i came to know is you
just
as long as you're call you're you're
you're trying
you're working towards a goal
um and you do the minimum amount of work
you show up on time
they uh things seem to work out
um and it's usually when
like you get loaded all night or
something like that and then you don't
show up to work the next day that's when
[ __ ] gets weird
um and that's i mean i can't
stress that enough part of my story my
life story is that
you know i would be way ahead of my life
game right now where i'm at
where i wanted to be and where i saw
myself
at my age i'm almost 50 years old um
i would i would i can only imagine
but i i would always build it up and
tear it down and i'd
build it up and tear tore it down for a
[ __ ] 10 years at least
at least that i can remember you know
beside you know
and have a fairly good memory but
there's a lot of stuff i just probably
want to black out because
what techniques would you use to tear it
down well here's drugs
yeah so here's how here's how it went
for me for for 10 years so you know like
i got established in how you know like i
built up
it gets to where my what i was trying to
get to is as i i had i have fairly good
footing here
and doors were open for me um
you know because i knew how to open them
and then
so i and then i work really hard and
i'm fairly good at what i do whatever
that is and i pay attention
um and i know that what people need
was employers they need someone who
shows up on time um pays attention
and does what they're what they're asked
to do and i just did that so things
i was able to get to where i wanted to
be pretty where i thought i wanted to be
pretty quickly
so that happened but what i didn't have
was ability on my social
side after work ended was to manage that
and i did a very important job of
managing my my
my life beyond work if i if i just
worked all the time it would've been
[ __ ]
great but if i wanted to have like a
social life friends
women uh you know that's where [ __ ] got
terrible and
um i would always get myself in this
really great position of a project or a
job
on a film or you know or working with
someone who i
wanted to work with and i do could
really great for the first week because
i was all about it
and even though internally i was still
all about it but then again it was just
like let's go party
and then so i'd go out and party and i'd
end up
[ __ ] just not showing up or not
calling and showing up
or you know getting arrested or some
crazy [ __ ] would always happen so i
would build it up and smash it down
and that and it would start off as
innocent as like
you know like the next morning like i
haven't slept all night i've been up all
night with some crazy hooker that i just
or
whatever i just met and then you know
like i got to go to work in four minutes
and i'm like [ __ ]
working four minutes you know and i show
up and i'm like all twisted out and i'm
trying to act normal and people are like
you're okay i'm like yeah i'm okay
and uh you know that's that starts as
that and then it's then it goes to like
i'm not showing up at all
and then so that happens and then
so it's it's like it goes a little bit
stages of worse and worse and worse
and then so of course you know when i
don't show up at all those people never
call me again i never work with those
people again this is cocaine that you're
finding yeah
cooking crack because so yeah well
that's how you know when i first moved
here
i i didn't know where to get drugs
in l.a and back in the day back then you
could just
crack cocaine like 10 years ago you
could buy anywhere
on sunset boulevard or hollywood
boulevard it was just available so i
just
drive around one day and honestly really
what i really just wanted was a smoker
joint
and i pulled up to these guys on
hollywood hollywood and la brea
and i asked them for uh you know that
anyway no it just cracked
and i said okay um well all right
[ __ ] give me some crack then
and so i i wasn't twenty dollars worth
of crack and i went back to the place
where
i had gotten my place living in bel air
and
the guest house i was like the kato
kaelin back then i lived in a guesthouse
where these
loyal people and on beverly glen
and i just smoked that up and like 20
minutes later i was like back right at
the same corner again
buy more crack and that's how it started
and then once i knew where to get it
you know and then back then it was so
easy to get like you could literally go
to hollywood boulevard
and la brea and anywhere between la brea
and highland
on hollywood boulevard day or night you
could buy crack
on the street like right in front of
manchester united's theater it was there
24
7. it was just available and i lived
right down the block
so for the next 10 years like
i literally would like you know be in
the middle of a job and i just
they had to run out somewhere and run
down from the studio i'd run out of the
block and i'd go grab some crack and
wreck
and be doing that and then so
you know all these things are in place
right and then i so i
back to what you said i was like
smashing it down so i it got so
bad so it's a point where like i just i
i would
be so [ __ ] spun out in my mind from
like i would just go on crack vendors
that would last for days
and then of course in your mind like you
know you're [ __ ] your life up and you
know that you're destroying everything
you've built up
and you know that your girlfriend and
your family are all going to be so
[ __ ] disappointed in you
that just makes it you know and you're
in your mind that makes it worse and it
makes it just propel itself to something
even more
and um i i did that and i didn't for the
point where like emotionally
and spiritually like i was just like
shot the [ __ ] out
and i didn't know what to do so what it
when
for me when i don't know what to do or
run away
so i'd run back to new york and i go to
and i'd get in the plane and i'd fly to
new york
and i go to my parents house and i'd
[ __ ] hide in their in their living
room
and the bedroom i grew up as a kid for
about a week
and then i would be like okay i'm done
with this
and i'll be ready for the building
backups section stage
in which i would build it back up you
know i'd go out to the gym i'd eat right
you know i'd totally stay away from
drugs and alcohol and i would do that
for like about
you know a couple weeks and then i you
know i would get back on the phone and
do the next thing you know like i i take
a job
excuse me in new york in the city and i
get a job as on a project new york
that's
you know has an important role
in the process of film and television
and i take that and by this point i've
been clean for probably about 30 or
40 days and i'd be in the city and then
be and we'd be out meeting a club or
something
and then of course some drugs come into
play and i've got this really amazing
job and everything's going so [ __ ]
great and my friends around me are all
so proud of me
and then i [ __ ] don't show up the
next day
and you know they see me walking around
the lower east side of manhattan
all cracked out when i'm supposed to be
at work and i catch they catch me in the
street that's how it always
[ __ ] happen someone i know like dude
aren't you supposed to be at work are
you okay man where's your jacket i'm
gonna be like
you know like and it's just it
even at that moment it felt [ __ ]
terrible but you just know you're
[ __ ] up your life again and
these are the people that care about you
the most and for me that's like a big
deal and
you just can't help it man and you do it
and you just
and i would smash it to the ground there
and then i would feel like i can't
do anything in new york because my
resources are all right so i jump in the
plane and go back to la
and i come back to la and i'd do the
same thing here and i would stay with my
ex-girlfriend and she'd help me and i
would
i would build it back up and i'd get
this amazing job and then i would
you know be in the middle of this
amazing project and i'd go out one night
and next thing you know
i'm [ __ ] in the alleyway with no
shoes
and um and i'm lost
and i you know i have no resources left
you know now she's
is like just upset calling my mother and
like what is he doing again and then you
know and i did this thing where i'd go
from new york to la
back and forth back and forth every six
months or four months
for 10 years and i did that and it was
[ __ ] exhausting
and all right it really and then what
really and then
in between that i did a bunch of great
work
you know a bunch of great work and a
bunch of good stuff
really good stuff and made a bunch of
money but i was never able to hold on to
any of it
because of you know my my
my social ability sucked um i guess if
this well i'll say you know and
you know i dabbled a little bit in a.a
and a lot of my good friends from here
and i'm very fortunate in here i have a
lot of good friends here
and they're not like really they're not
like you know friends that like
they are attached to me because i have
anything for them either you know which
is a lot of what people are today
like i'm friends with this guy because
you know he's whatever and he has you
know he's cool
they're just friends of mine because
they're my friends and they care about
me
so but they're all sober and they've
been sober for many many years
and they understand the dynamic they
understand what it's like
so it's it's um you know it's a
connection that's very important to me
so i you know i was able to like get a
little bit of sobriety underneath my
belt
um for a hot second and
then it's then i started that part of
you know my existence is is struggling
with you know being sober or unsober
you know i've probably been i've been to
betty ford i've been to
uh passage i know i've been to [ __ ]
every rehab
i was went you know and my parents
aren't wealthy people
but you know okay and um you know the
amount of money that my family
spent in you know and trying to help me
is [ __ ] obnoxious really it's sad
it's like it's like a that makes me feel
terrible and stuff because you know
you know they're they spent a lot of
money is rehab the answer
no i mean you know and i say this to a
lot of people rehab is not for you
rehabs for the okay i'm going to rehab
to keep my job i'm going rehab is for
your job rehab is for your
your mother rehab is for your girlfriend
rehab is for
you know the people there and things
that are close to you in your life
to attach themselves to an idea that you
are getting better
because without rehab there's no way to
say well billy's
you know better now why is he any better
today than yesterday oh because he went
to rehab
so he went to rehab so now he's okay um
which is in my experience not really
gonna work out it will when billy wants
to get sober
when billy is done when billy's tired of
it
but that has to be that's billy's choice
and
some make it and others don't
and like living down here now in my
studio
and my shop and my office are all here
and i live here too as well
and this is skid row right what's they
call the arts district but it's [ __ ]
skid row
and um you know i i'm a
i'm a fairly friendly guy and i i've
become friends with
quite a few of the of the people that
are
unfortunately live in tents out here and
you know they all have drug problems and
they're all struggling with it and
they're
all you know and um
that's you know i don't hate to say but
that's the ones that are not
gonna get it you know and
i feel for them
but at the same time it's their choice
you know
some of them and not as much of the ones
that i taught i
interact with a lot because i try to
keep my distance from some
that aren't fully aware of what's going
on around them
there's a lot of mental illness down
there like down here is [ __ ] buttload
of mental illness and
it's [ __ ] terrible to see and it's
different degrees and different stages
but there are some that are really sick
and
there's are there mildly but
you can tell and um i i just you know
it's best to i don't know but the guys i
talk to are dudes that are fully capable
of doing something different
they could leave they could get a job
they could change their lives and
you know and within a certain amount of
time if they wanted to do it
they could be you know like your brother
whoever you know like they're different
than anyone you know or i know
they could do it because they have to
want to do it um and they'd have to feel
in their heart
you know they have to want that you know
and i and it's hard and i gotta get it
too because after a while
of living in a certain way and being a
certain person
you just don't see anything else you
know um and it's
been fortunate enough for me it's never
been my case again because i have a
really strong family
um they're not gonna ever let me [ __ ]
forget that so
it's different from i think it's
different for me but like some of these
guys they don't
you know like they could and i try to
help them you know i try to give a job i
try to
you know um and hopefully they spend
their money wisely
but you know a lot of them don't you
know they may
they say they do or they don't but um
it's uh you know it's his choices
yeah i've i i um
i had a really bad experience um amongst
many bad experiences
but after a while it kind of builds up
and you get to a point where like
you're just like you know you just
[ __ ] are done you just had like
and i was fortunate enough to again
because i had family and
friends and people around me that were
like you know
they cared about me i
i just i i had i've gone to a point of
like with another girlfriend and there's
always a girl right there's always a
[ __ ] girl involved
and um even now today there's still a
[ __ ] girl involved
and i just had losing my mind one day
and i
was living out of a prop truck that i
had stolen
basically from a production for another
uh country artist that probably would
want to [ __ ] kill me today if he saw
him because i just took off with his
prop truck in the
and the day before shooting and i was
living out of this truck
and i had a girlfriend and that whole
thing and i was at least in the back of
this truck and the side of the road and
and
echo park somewhere and i just wanted to
[ __ ] hang myself i just
was like i just wanted to die you know i
just was like i can't
do this like i'm
you know you know you're like you know
that you're smarter than this and you're
better than this but you're just like
you can't
stop ending up like this this is [ __ ]
nuts dude and like
so i had talked to i
mentioned a lot of friends were sober
and they're you know always available to
help me
and i had my phone in my pocket and i
pocket dialed this one dude who
was worked as a as a job was to find
deep rehabs for people who wanted to get
clean
and um i pocket dialed him and they and
like i remember hearing out of my pocket
i was just sitting in their truck and i
was drinking this 20 of like keep having
malt liquor
and i heard multi well justin and i come
out of my pocket and i'm like what the
[ __ ]
and i pocket dialed him and he said
what's up dude i was like oh i don't
know me
are you okay i was like yeah i'm all
right man i'm alive
he goes are you ready to get clean or
what are you ready to get sober dude
like
you had enough and uh i was like yeah
man
i think i have you know and he came
to control over you know that night you
know within an hour he was there and he
followed you know he drove me over to
where the truck needed to go and i
dropped the truck off
and he put me in the car and he you know
and uh i you know he stayed with him and
a friend that night and then
you know he found i had called another
friend of mine and he uh he put me up
for a few days while i
kind of you know was able to follow you
know
but long story short is easy started to
help me start the road
you know i was ready that's my point
like i was ready dude i was just
tired of being a [ __ ] crackhead or
junkie or just like being a
fuck-up constantly you know just like
letting people down and
you know like people extending their
hands of kindness to me and me just like
throwing it back in their face with like
you know that really wasn't and and most
of them knew this but it's just like sad
to see
like a grown-ass man like ruining his
life constantly
you know it's hard to witness on the
other end because now i do it today i
see it in front of me i'm just like [ __ ]
dude
i'm dealing with right now it's this
moment like right now like some girl
took off with my car
and i thought she was a friend of mine
and i had no i thought she was normal i
had no idea that she was capable of this
and you know and she's my car right now
this moment is missing she's driving
around i don't know what [ __ ] she is
and i don't want to call the police
because i don't want to get her arrested
but you know it's a brand new car they
could easily find and the gps would have
to call the police in order for him to
do that
and it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] situation her
boyfriend
is no help and he's a good friend of
mine and
it's just you know you know
it's just choices you know and
it's you know it's just a car but and i
hope she's okay um
i it's just my point is this [ __ ] just
happens you know and
and i'm sure that it's it has something
to do with some sort of drug or
something she's like doing something
that's that's like making her not make
the best decisions right now
and um
yeah you know and i was kind of in a
position where
you know she was helping me out with
this
thing i was doing or and and i didn't
want to keep her waiting and i had
another meeting i had to go to in a
valley
and i just told her to drop me off and
come back in a few hours and pick me up
and
she dropped me off and she never came
back and i don't know where [ __ ] she is
so um but as far as we go back i was
just done so
and and my friend todd he um who
actually passed away recently
um helped me get clean man he
i get the path of changing my life
really is what i would call because
i just life was different from me then
you know like i could not
wrap my hand around anything normal for
any good time like like people having an
apartment
people having like a you know a bank
account
you know and just being like the the
basic
blocks that make you a regular person
like a
functioning member of society i could
not do it i just couldn't do it it was
like you're check casting places and
[ __ ] scrambling or you know like or
just like i mean
cash money and then yeah and no a real
place to live i'd have like i'd rent a
room from some stranger for like a month
and then
it wouldn't work out because either he's
crazy or i'm not getting or whatever
never happened and god it took [ __ ]
forever and then when i went to rehab
this
one that last time actually when it
wasn't the last time
i went to uh i but i was serious about
[ __ ] changing my life i had [ __ ]
been done
i was probably in my early 40s and i
could just see the horizon of my life
where it could possibly go you know i
could go this way you know and
potentially
be you know end up like it's fortunately
living in a tent downtown
you know just making crack my daily
[ __ ] thing
or i could do something else you know
and
i'm fortunate enough to just to know to
know that that's not really what i want
to do you know it's just
and i don't know how it is for other
people and i don't know how a lot of
people end up in the positions that they
do down here
but i live here in like my places right
next door to
work like i live here and i'm here all
day all night and i said [ __ ] that i see
happening
[ __ ] bananas and it's all because of
you know people's drug problems really
and
but again a lot of them are there are
quite a few people here that are
generally mentally ill
um and it's painful to [ __ ] see
um it's painful to see some of the
people here
and it's unfortunate because they're not
getting what they need you know
the drug addiction masks the mental
illness yeah
it does but i look at someone i just
know that maybe it's like you
know a lot of people just take too many
hits and there's like one hit
that just you know and it's that's it
you're never the same
um and i had a friend of mine in high
school who passed away a little while
ago
it was the same he's a brilliant kid and
then he just did too much of
you know he did too much acid and he was
never the [ __ ] same person again
he's just never the same i watched it
happen in front of my eyes and i saw it
happen
you know he he took ten hits of acid one
night and and i didn't see him for two
days and he came back and he was not the
same person
it's not the same guy um still my best
friend but just
not the same dude he was a week before
um
but i i just uh i was not i was
ready to like do something different and
i was scared
the way i fell in that truck was scared
like i was like really take my life
i just like had it with this [ __ ]
lifestyle
you know and like seeing all these other
other friends of mine doing so well
like you know and friends over at the
[ __ ] you know
award shows and getting like all these
guys who were like i started their
careers
and they're you know way beyond me
and i'm not even able to [ __ ] figure
out where i'm going to sleep that night
and it's because i just could not
[ __ ] get
grounded in in life because it's just i
was [ __ ] junkie
i was just a junkie i was a drug addict
it's just
what i what i did and even to this day i
i just
like wearing that around your neck like
a badge
is not something i really want to do
um a lot of people identify with it like
i just want to run away from that [ __ ]
as far as i can go like
i've i lived it i don't want to go back
to that
um so i i went to rehab and i
was very lucky and todd got me in a
really cool rehab which is
you know on the water and it's called
see i'll call it and say it was
so-called sea change and a bunch of
really amazing people there
um that just gave a [ __ ]
and for me in my experience when you're
around people that really care
that really care about what they're
doing
i mean it's that's it you know you know
you could have been to some reasons
before that where
it's a job for some people you can tell
um they do what they've got to do but
it's you know you can feel it you know
so these people really give a [ __ ] and
they help me
they did they really did and i started
to like you know
cool out and i stayed in rehab for i
just finally this time like i did what
the [ __ ] they said
to do like don't leave after 30 days
don't just go back to your regular life
because
before this i i need to work i need to
get back in my career i need to do this
i
just you know in my brain i had this i
had to get going again but
yeah sure i'll keep going again but
you're in [ __ ] two months you're
gonna be right back here again
that's what happened every [ __ ] time
so i just did what they said you know i
did what the [ __ ] they said i
i followed their direction and i stayed
you know
and i um i stayed for 90 days
and but after the 90 days i didn't go
back i would have stayed in i lived in
there
and i lived in the uh um
you know can you uh what i forget what
they call it the uh
transitional yeah transitional housing
which is basically how long was your
whole stay
for five months or five months and and
even before it prior to this like you're
a few years prior
before this i had gotten stuck in new
york city
and my parents you know before this
right
about two two or three years before this
i had gotten [ __ ] out of my just
like [ __ ] out of my mind again and
gotten stuck in new york city
when i was actually living in la i went
there for a job
i was supposed to come right back and
end up getting high and then like
no money and at this point a lot of my
friends and my family
were on the road somebody like [ __ ] we
can't help you anymore you have to help
yourself
this is the kind of thing and my parents
went into the phone call none of my
friends would answer their phones
and i had nowhere to go and i remember
it was cold and it was like i had
nowhere i
had realized at this point i had nowhere
to go like i had no
place to turn i had no when to call and
that prepared us i always did there was
always a girl an ex-corporate
or a girlfriend or a friend or someone
to call to go to their house or someone
to rescue me in some sort of way
and i had none of that and that was the
first time i ever felt that
and i didn't know what the [ __ ] to do
and i had nowhere to go and like it's
cold i'm hungry
like i'm just walking around aimlessly
and like like
i feel bad for home people who are
homeless because
i've been there man and for a brief
amount of time i've been there with
nowhere to go
nothing to do with no money like nothing
it's [ __ ] terrifying
it really is and it's a [ __ ] position
that i don't want to ever be in
again and that's another reason why
you know i pay attention to what i'm
doing now and uh
i had nowhere to go then so i couldn't i
went to a hotel lobby and i looked at
the phone book
and i just looked under you know what
you know help or rehab there i forgot
what i did but i found this place called
uh what the [ __ ] is it called um oh
it'll come to me
but it was a rehab sort it was like a
christian based
day top day it was called day top i
don't know if i can say that
but it's called daytop and i called
these people and they had a
and they had like a office in midtown
manhattan which was a few blocks
and i walked over there and there was
this this dude and he was you know
he brought me in i called him he said
come on over right now
and he said you have nowhere to go and i
was like no man he's like all right man
we'll
we'll take you in a minute and they they
took me in and
it was like a rehab but not really a.a
base we're kind of like christian based
and it was it was a kind of an unusual
situation but anyways i went there and i
stayed there it was called a therapeutic
community
and i stayed there for like six months
and um
but i was not ready yet and i was more
distressed about this relationship i had
with a girl
that i could not wrap my [ __ ] hands
around [ __ ] up and i was just out of
my brain
really i was crazy with that [ __ ] and
smoking crack did not help at all
and i was not getting i was not
available i was not available yet to see
my partner and
and and mentally
heal myself i guess the basics the
building blocks of
getting your life straight again this is
okay desire to do so
desire to do so is the most important
part like
all and and i am i'm very lucky
like i have a lot of people that care
about me and like
you know there were that stuck around
through
[ __ ] that i you know like i did some
[ __ ] that like i'm so [ __ ]
embarrassed about
to this day um
that like i just it's just bad you know
and
uh you know like sexual [ __ ] but like i
would just
you know like steal [ __ ] from my friends
who like we're trying to
you know like one time this guy let me
stay in his house he was a good friend
he's a he was a good friend of a good
friend of mine and we were kind of
friends in new york city and he let me
stay in this house
because i had nowhere to go and my buddy
would not let me stay in his house
and he let me crash myself i [ __ ]
stole his computer and this [ __ ]
distilled
my crack and his ho it was just and even
to this day every time i see
we talked you know and i paid him back
eventually um
we still it's it still feels weird when
i talked to him this was like 15 years
ago
so um to get clean and to get your life
together leaves the desire to do so you
have to have that you have to want to
and that's what like i said a lot of
people
are in this in the neighborhood i live
in now now here it's
they don't have that desire they've
either lost it
or never had a desire to do anything
different because they don't know any
better
like if you know i had a
baby and i've raised the baby and [ __ ]
and i all i gave him was [ __ ]
and all he baby knew as [ __ ] that's all
the baby knows is [ __ ]
so it's gonna gravitate towards [ __ ] at
least in my experience
and that's sad um and a lot of
people that i interact with here i don't
honestly feel that they've ever seen or
known anything any better or been told
that there was anything better for them
which is [ __ ] awful and
you know criminal really it's like
there's no reason for people to be
treated such way
and um so desire to get better
is the big one you have to get bet you
don't have to want it you know because
people threw sobriety and and different
you know like
in my face all the time and i just i
couldn't see it i didn't want it
you know i wanted what i thought was the
right thing for me and i didn't
[ __ ] have any idea but um
that's the biggest part and then you
have to
um align yourself with the right people
you know like i would have never i
i would have [ __ ] been i'd be dead by
now i would be dead
there was no i would not be sitting here
today if there wasn't for the people in
my life
i had people that cared enough about me
or just cared at all
to you know to say something
you know that's why whenever i have the
opportunity to say anything or help
anybody in the smallest amount of way i
can and push them in the right direction
i try to do so
as obligated as a human being um
and what they do with it from there is
their choice
but you have to use i have to say do
something
um so i had that and that's
really important um and really i mean
it's the desire to do so you have to
have that desire you have to want
something different you know and like i
just was so [ __ ] tired of being
shoeless in an alleyway
you know when the week before that like
i was like in my mind balling
and now i'm [ __ ] i have i'm like i'm
just lost
um you have to not want
to have that anymore and you know that's
the next those are two real extremes
right like the [ __ ] extreme
situations and that's my story that's
how it was for me
but other people aren't like that
they're just mildly [ __ ] up or like
like they just might like
kind of [ __ ] up their lives right or
they kind of
you know um are not doing great
because they're you know but they have
they don't
they don't know what they're capable of
yet because they haven't really they
haven't really uh
done anything yet i don't know you know
i i know what it
worked for me and i know that for close
friends of mine who have
been sober and have great lives today
you know like rich full eyes with family
and friends and
you know and they're you know they're
doing things
for themselves and other people you know
they live a rich life
um those guys did it that's how they did
it they
they just had a desire to do so and and
i i did
i i used aaa and and i don't think that
a is for everyone but i know that it
[ __ ] works
um and it worked for me um
and i [ __ ] hate be honest like i
don't i don't hate aa but i hate
that i have to be a part of it i hate
that i i
don't like that i have to do this
because i can't [ __ ] manage my own
life
that i'm not man enough to just keep my
[ __ ] together
but the truth is i'm not or i haven't
been
and that's accepting that and like
looking yourself in the [ __ ] mirror
and being like okay with it and and
and only owning it is a big part of it
too like
a lot of people live in [ __ ] a
fantasy [ __ ] world man
where they're like you know
it may work out for them i don't know
but i lived in a [ __ ] fantasy world
for a long time
and it didn't work out for me
it seemed like it was but it was never
it was
never sustainable not sustainable at all
um so
you know as you navigate through life
you i
picked up things that um
and picked up contents and ideas and
i was able to understand myself um
to the point where like i know that i
you know like not to you know
be around certain things or you know not
to go to you know
i i don't but aaa was the biggest thing
um
and i got sober in a.a and i got sober
in the pacific group
which is like a [ __ ] high ver it was
like a a more annoying version
of aaa but it works a lot for like and
that
it's odd it's odd that i ended up my
studio and my shop
ended up here it is because the pacific
group is really big on going down to
skid row
and helping out skid row guys who are
really in need of help and they need a
little bit more structure
they feel they feel that these guys need
these people
need more structure than you know the
average piece of because and they
[ __ ] probably do
because you know like i said just have
never had anything
like structure they don't know what it
is working now
in the middle of drug central it's a
problem or a temptation for you
of course it is yeah it is it is
um however is that a bad decision
no i it's weird how life works you know
life is a [ __ ] is a as has [ __ ]
comedy
built into it it's and it's just
i mean like when i think about how the
what how things happened and
came back to me ending up here it's like
you know areas
and um but it's it's life and life
i i feel that like my world that i live
in right
i live in a world where the life wants
you to do good
you know this universe and this place
that we all live in
wants you to do well and it wants you to
do good
you are [ __ ] up uh but it's gonna
keep giving good good things to you
every day it's gonna give you
opportunities to do good things or make
life better for yourself and for the
people around you
well how you deal with it is up to you
you're [ __ ] it up
it's not anyone else or anything else or
any other thing
it's you and it happens to me every day
here um
it is quite ironic that i am here um and
it is a lot of temptation
it is but you know i live you live in
hollywood
you know like you want drugs man they're
anywhere you can
go anywhere to get that uh
i've been on and off for two years you
know i don't
i i got to the point where like i i
don't
you know i have a couple drinks now and
then um i just i don't want to lie to
anybody
um you know i drink a bit and but that's
it
you know i don't go yeah i work
and here's how i found my life you know
and what i ended up
in is i just work i work all the time
and i work so much that like i don't
really have anything
else besides work which has now become a
problem for me
because i had a girlfriend for many
years and she helped me with my business
and like
after i had gotten sober i met her then
and we were together and i just was like
[ __ ] work and building up my life
and you know staying clean and and she
was all huge part of that
and you know we're together for like
four or five years and
towards the end now which is recently
the end
a couple months ago uh i just i had no
other i had
i was not dynamic at all i was just a
guy that worked
and i'm pretty sure it got boring for
her
um because i didn't want to do anything
she wanted to go hiking she wanted to go
drive cross country to see my family i
wanted to work
and that kind of killed it uh
so i learned another lesson right there
and
i did not want us to separate at all and
she took off with a guy that used to
work for me i got her a job babysitting
for him
and she took off him and uh
i've talked to her since it's their life
lessons continue
yeah they do but they too they do and uh
yeah because i it was just a
one-dimensional character that just
[ __ ] worked all the time and didn't
want to do anything else and
you know i don't know but women want to
do other things
they want other things in their life you
know uh
and i didn't see that and that was being
selfish
really is what it was i was being
selfish with my
my spirit and my and you know when
you're
in my experience if you're a woman and
you know you you're
required to make her happy it's part of
the requirement
and i was not really paying attention to
that part of it
i just thought she was going to be there
no matter what and maybe she probably
stuck around for a while
because i've been like this for a while
and um
[Music]
she hadn't had enough and she saw an
opportunity to do something else and she
took it and i was
[ __ ] real angry about it for a long
time and i'm still upset man but
i understand that like
nice you know it's my fault and just
there's no way you know like
it's something she didn't care about or
loved me it's that i just was
you know just
she didn't see any uh would see me going
any other way you know
i don't know how to say it but it
happened
and you know what i'm gonna do so uh
yeah so my in my my
my life story is uh is you know
uh riddled with uh
goods and that like you know great stuff
and
and amazing experiences and cool things
that i've done and but
what's always destroyed it was
my decision to like
you know party and
the party has been over for quite a
while you know and in my
and like losing you do a bunch of really
cool things like you work really hard
and then you celebrate with a party
right so you know we
worked really hard and we're gonna
celebrate party this weekend
that's where you're supposed to do it
but what happens with me and i
know a lot of other people is the party
becomes every day we party
and then it turns into something else
and then the party turns into a job
itself or like a you know defines you as
who you are
and then you turn it like a junkie um so
yeah i'm i'm i'm
i'm pretty grateful for uh
the people and um
the experiences that i've had to get me
to where
i was able to get to today because there
was a period of time where like i
i a lot of people had probably wrote me
off
as you know i was going to be in the
gutter probably dead
um and that sucks
but i was that's that's who i was you
know that's what i did
i did that you know i lived that i made
those decisions
so um yeah i'm pretty grateful today for
where i'm at i'm able to
to help other people um i'm available to
help myself and my family and um
[Music]
yeah it's um i'm glad to i'm i'm
glad i was able to tell this yeah to the
world
for sure yeah thank you all right thank
you just